hello reject nation it's greg al-baqir
and it's John here so John yeah what
we're gonna watch the very first trailer
ever and finally there's a trailer out
for transformers the last night oh boy
really and even though it's the first
trailer people think it's the best
trailer and so many comments what no no
that is this y'all using supposedly the
final trailer
no good the final trailer yeah like the
tears I like that they denote that man
don't worry guys this is goal of what
anymore let this violator
get any more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are now some need except
you want to know go to to make is coming
here the kidnapping on her first
transform experience nice both Whitney
[Music]
thousand years this kitchen yeah I am
like I receive a biscuit transformers
yeah not to save our continue you must
unlock the past
[Music]
ouch we do science it was a beanbag go
to be me until they go through me it's
climbing thanks Mike
I am
[Music]
that's shocking
[Music]
alexsei
[Music]
what was that but wow it's reassembly oh
no like a liquid Terminator with my next
3d cameras damn straight it was skipped
through that writer's block like whoa
like all ten - Wow
you know the is a film imax 3d cameras
with the aspect ratio changes sometimes
I don't know if you noticed that like
watch look at the look on last 20
seconds of the trailer look at the
letterbox okay okay okay - the
letterboxes let's see yeah I see em I
see em see it's it okay
Oh watching watch we know audio oh yeah
there's like a little purse this is like
film and then this is ID extradition
yeah he did it I mean I goin all out for
this one man I saw agent extinction and
a lot of that was shot was a special
IMAX camera it's not like the Noland
style where it's whoops the whole street
mom but if it was still like IMAX
quality it took them more than the
average film would on an IMAX screen and
that made the experience way more
enjoyable people Bagon age of extinction
but i had a great time watching it
simply because of the IMAX experience
honestly there's no other way I want to
watch the movie I'm not a big
Transformers fan by any capacity
whatsoever in but if I'm going to watch
it I'm probably going to do my best to
get tickets for an IMAX screening
because that's the best way to watch it
you want just to enjoy the pure action
experience time acts is the best way to
go this is a IMAX promo we are doing
right now yeah I feel like if you want
to get the most out of your time and
your and your investment if you're going
to watch this at all yelling that's what
these are for like a you know like these
are in some ways keeping with the inner
experience of lives by we add up like
this and
like that's how I would the only way I
think it would work really well you know
it's like you said every time like they
always hook me and they they hope to me
with this like I like the approach of
like weird space Lord of the Rings
transformers like and you got a lot of
nerdy characters in there too you do you
do yeah just look like it's gonna be a
long answer movie like oh no they're
also locked all these things know how
are all these gonna fit again that is
this one is going to be especially long
and maybe like four hours they don't
like breach three hours probably a lot
of them as close to here though there
was a nerdy characters like when we saw
that clip with the kids I like the
stranger things kids those are awesome
and I also like how many tournaments the
dirty black dude in this one makes money
who is that guy have I seen a guy before
I have no idea what's tonight everybody
was fine yeah you know I'm he's leaning
back
he always they always get me to it with
like good supporting comedic characters
you know like that was the whole reason
I want to see part for whatever was for
teaching early yeah you know and like it
here yeah like I'm excited actually like
I'm more excited for Mark Wahlberg story
because of that character on it and
they're excited to see that character
kind of curious to see where Mark
Wahlberg's character I seems like they
evolved him a little more
he doesn't look like the same old family
man he looks kind of like a tired guy
yeah he's tired it over this it looks
like they made him a much more
heightened fictional type of character
who's a badass sir in the transformers
age you know like as opposed to like a
dad as rebellious daughter and he has
this career that's not really going
anywhere and working with cars and stuff
it's too old for this but he's still
been yeah and the Dinobots good webs are
going to be a lot more included I'm
still planning on watching the
transformers cartoon before this movie
comes out I don't know if I'm going to
rewatch all the Transformers I just
don't think I just needed to go to help
come on at the same time just kind of
looking at one screen to the next I make
Shia LaBeouf I do too I'm in under a low
buff I do I think Shia LaBeouf was great
I loved it in the first Transformers
movie here's my favorite part of the
first job
you know he was just the right pitch for
that because like you know he could
carry it off because he's a good enough
actor they could carry off but he's old
like Shia LaBeouf so he's got like a
little bit of a kind of weird edgy charm
yeah and that yeah I thought that really
works for these well he's like as do we
be dude he's relatable and I miss I miss
having he likes stroke yeah I miss
having him in here they gonna be cool if
they could get him and Mark Wahlberg in
a movie together
transformers that'd be cool I would be
excited for every a cool part sick you
know with terrence malick steps in makes
a new Transformers movie maybe that Jeff
about full agree cuz like I watched part
of his all my movies thing at my desk
and like when one of the Transformers
movies is on he looked depressed do you
love it so so he was like some down he
was kind of staring like his I just
looked dead like there's a staring
straight so yeah I don't think you would
ever do it but like I kind of want him
Connelly I have hope that he would do it
be able Megan Fox that that [ __ ] from
the third wasn't dead that everyone
thought was a bad actress you know we
got all that you know what the bubble I
think that was bumblebee who was
reassembling himself I was named t1000
yeah yeah I also kind of mad at me of an
age of Ultron or the ayran giant of the
Iron Giant
that's like the cool robot thing to do
yeah all the parts are far but it's like
a Tony Stark thing yeah it looks a lot
like that yeah it's absolutely all
moving parts and plates and things yeah
now like because of where technology is
realism we could watch y'all screw
together and I feel like that
reassembling moment was pretty cool and
I think that could work to his advantage
bumblebee in terms of like a fight
situation oh yeah it was like when the
video a like messed up by Optimus Prime
it might be able to come in handy maybe
he gets messed up I often describe
disassembles we all think he dies and
then we saw the trailer so we knows I'm
gonna have like bumblebee until missing
a hand where's that hand
[Music]
alright guys well thanks for sending
that our way okay you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects click the notification melt as
well John is that John Humphrey debt on
Instagram and Twitter
he's also the social media manager of
Blum house and the real rejects right
hey we launched the patreon not long ago
so many awesome rewards on there we have
t-shirts now that you can get we have a
lot of exclusive content of talking
behind the scenes deleted takes
Pig many blogs a lot of the gives two
pictures oh yeah but it's a lot of fun
over that mince man so go to check out
our patreon or pavor become a part of
our community there it's much more
personal in here
here where's the distance we're like
totally different people like totally
different cool normally it's like you
see it there and you would think we're
priests in the trailer that played that
tropic thunder yeah we'll be Maguire and
Robert Downey jr.